harry styles and olivia wilde
hollywood's newest
golden couple
[Music]
here's what we know the 26 year old
singer and 36 year old actress director
were recently spotted in santa barbara
holding hands
at a wedding e.t has learned that the
pair attended nuptials for harry's
manager
jeff azoff and get this according to tmz
he even officiated the ceremony
after the could be couple was
photographed again
arriving back at harry's home in l.a i
enjoyed the experience a lot
as for how olivia and harry first linked
up
well they're currently working together
olivia is directing harry in don't worry
darling
a psychological thriller centered around
an unhappy housewife
in the 1950s in november's vogue where
harry made history as the first solo
male star to grace the cover
olivia opened up about working with the
singer and even revealed she did
a little victory dance when he was
officially cast in her film
she praised harry telling the mad quote
to me he's very modern and i hope that
this brand of confidence as a male that
harry has
truly devoid of any traces of toxic
masculinity
is indicative of his generation and
therefore the future of the world
meanwhile also in november a source
confirmed to et that olivia and her
fiance of nine years
actor jason sudeikis had called it quits
i don't know anything yet but the most
important thing is that being engaged is
a wonderful
beautiful feeling let's just enjoy it
there's my rush
together they share six-year-old son
otis and four-year-old daughter daisy
i'm just every day more grateful and
realizing how i've completely won the
life lottery and it's just so clear to
me at every stage of his
growth and my own growth as a mother so
it just makes me realize how lucky i am
the source explained there was no drama
they just didn't work out as a couple
but continue to be each other's biggest
supporters
which was exactly the case when e.t
spoke with jason in november the day
before
news of their split broke olivia her
production of don't worry darling got
shut down for a little bit because of
some positive tests so
how is she doing with all this i know
she was really loving directing this
oh she loves it and she's great in it
and it's like
a um yeah it's not easy it's amazing
the to see her resilience and and she
just you know she just
works her butt off they're i think a
week into their 14-day hiatus and
they got they get another week but you
know she's editing the stuff they
already shot you know
she's using her time you know and she
has so many other projects in the
in the works that she you know she's
she's uh
kicks ass that way